you want to know how I know I'm grown up
my favorite thing about Christmas
Christmas pants
Hank today's video comes to you in for
very special parts part one the
beckoning of lovely you may remember
that on 8808 you and I and a bunch of
nerdfighters made a movie called the
beckoning of lovely with my friend and
mentor Amy Krauss Rosenthal
by the way Christmas tree you are no
longer seasonably appropriate it turns
out that the movie the beckoning of
lovely was the first part of an
ambitious and amazing project by Amy
called the beckoning of lovely for more
information check out the link in the
sidebar
part two Hank I don't know about you but
I'm still kind of reeling from the
project for awesome Sossamon Asst Hank
nerdfighters lobbied for literally
hundreds of great charities but in the
end I chose five that I'm giving $200
each - I mean - which I'm giving $200
each Oh prepositions you always get me
Save the Children Bangladesh the Wounded
Warrior Project the Susan G Komen
Foundation to benefit breast cancer wait
doesn't benefit breast cancer dip
detriments breast cancer MS research and
saved our fur where's your money going
Hank and nerdfighters if you were
inspired by the project for awesome to
give money to charity where'd your money
go part three CAPTCHA dictionary by the
way if you want to know what a CAPTCHA
code is you can always comment five
times on this video and then hit refresh
so YouTube's CAPTCHA codes are not
usually English words but they are
almost always sets of consonants and
vowels organized in such a way that they
could be words now Hank during the
project for awesome nerdfighters
commented on YouTube videos more than
200,000 times no joke and that meant a
lot of CAPTCHA codes some of which
sounded like made-up words that
nerdfighters then invented definitions
for ah for which nerdfighters then
invented definitions pwned so Hank here
are a few entries from the nerdfighter
CAPTCHA dictionary Camellia the euphoric
state in which a nerdfighter can comment
on 15 videos in one minute
nippy hat hello little hat you put on
your nibs to keep them warm rapey toe
the speed at which nerdfighters comment
brouk EULA vampire Brussels sprouts Hank
there can be no question that the bucola
are very beautiful but if you eat them
you will almost die although in the end
you will live happily ever after even
though the brook EULA are sort of
emotionally abusive hi Coco so an
endangered and possibly mythical
subspecies of ninja koala and finally
cootie oh ping which means
only transmitting cooties cootie oping
is a great word it reminds me of our
beloved grandmother's word for making
out skoodilypooping I Hank one time I
brought one of my high school
girlfriends over to meet and Hedy and
pawpaw and we got a little bit lost on
the way so we were late when we got
there I was like I'm sorry we got lost
and nanny said are you sure you weren't
skoodilypooping and my girlfriend was
like what the heck is skoodilypooping
and nanny just looked at her and said as
if you don't know god bless her heart
for Paper Towns questions Hank as we
wrap up the Paper Towns edition of the
nerdfighter blurbing book club I'm going
to do two videos in which I talk about
the book ideally I'd like to do this by
answering questions that you and other
nerdfighters may have about the book if
you have any questions about Paper Towns
leave them in comments Hank I'll see you
next week Merry Christmas way